hey you know what's what
let me ask you this man it was looking
kind of grim for you for a minute
were did you ever go through any sort of
phase of being depressed while you were
locked up oh yeah for sure i mean i was
fighting the death penalty like you
don't know like
it's always like you hear people fight
stuff like that so you'll never be like
you never think you're going to be that
person you sitting there and somebody
said that you're like whoa
that's not me then when you that person
you don't know when you just going to
court just to go to court
you don't know what's going on and not
offering you no deal
like you get crazy sometimes you get the
weather in like damn
am i ever going to get out right or even
if i do get out am i still going to be
relevant when i get out is it even going
to matter
who wants to get out of jail when
they're 40 something
how to be a rapper at 40's right come on
bro
luckily like i'm probably i'm gonna be
the biggest rapper ever to come out
because i'm the youngest like everybody
that went through like i'm 27 i just
turned 27
so like everybody gucci man all them
people when they was going through that
stuff they was all ordered to me when
they got out and started booming
i'm still in my 20s so i give it like
five more years and i must
try to do something else maybe